let's first discuss some of the elements
of your speech the first thing I think
is really what I would like to ask each
of the free panel members is to go back
to this idea of the good life so we'll
start with him and go back first we have
a long distinguished career at the
Rabobank you've been retired sometime in
our Chairman or various charities but
also chairman or four non-executive
board member of various companies 12
years ago you you retired as chief
financial officer of a wonderful bank
robber bank of course you were not paid
as much as bankers are paid today but
you know you were comfortably off so you
is it a sense that you could afford to
now run the Nexus Institute you're
chairman to fill in your life in a more
interesting way whereas in the book it's
this good life is it something is it a
fairly elitist thing it's a question
there maybe it's tough to say that to
somebody who's trying to struggle to me
against meat and they say you just work
15 hours of work less hours and they
can't even buy the food for the children
so in what sense is this good life in
you talk to you as an economist it may
be partially covered by your own
experience is it something for our type
of people or is it really something
which you can offer to the common man as
well I don't think that is the question
whether a small number of people have I
income or does that have an effect of
the good life of whole society there it
comes more to a let's say a policy of
bringing employments to give people the
chance to be participate in a society I
know a short an even distribution of
income but then has some value of course
but I guess you should make a
distinction between a personal income
and a
a social policy the quick intermezzo but
you're gonna get property so so could
you just give a yes or no answer
it's for you having a relatively equal
distribution of income part of your good
life yeah because it's the basis of
respect you can't have respect
if incomes are to unequally divided okay
so and some of your policies will go in
a direction as well but you have a
progressive consumption tax and things
it becomes wallet okay now we come to
your room you don't claim as so so again
the same question to you and as a
reaction to the lecture and then the
b-baby we go more details what's the
good life for you our banks really
contributing to the good life and I mean
I if you ask me that question personally
and also reading the book which is which
by the way I thought was a great book I
think the distinction between leisure
and work is not so black and white and I
believe very much in the vein of the
other speakers that it's really about
the quality of work and so I would seek
progress more in terms of making work
fulfilling than to say you know it's
black and white you know work is a slog
and leisure is great personally I can
completely enjoy my leisure I'm not
somebody who works all the time
takes know all this etc but I do think
that work also needs to be fulfilling
it's about participation but also about
using your skills developing doing new
things being creative making a
contribution to others that would be my
view so you need a well-functioning
economy and I think banks can contribute
to that
can I mean there are of course the
number of conditions for that
maybe we'll talk about later what can we
do about the current financial crisis
and they talk of any views on battle
I've got lots of views on that where I
if we want to fix this financial crisis
properly I think we should have less
fixation with short-term economic growth
because this the the economic problems
that we are in are extremely deep and I
think for example the the British
government made a major mistake by
basically telling the British people
it's going to be tough for a couple of
years but by the end of this government
we should be out of the EVAs I think the
true story should have been it might
very well take us two governments two
periods of 10 years 10 10 years to get
out of this to get out of this mess
and I think that we are so central
bankers and politicians are so extremely
worried about their still being an
economy tomorrow that we're doing all
sorts of things that are extremely risky
like monetary policies are extremely
unorthodox and never before have have
central banks increased their balance
sheet to such an extent as is happening
now and we do not know what the
long-term effects will be but that is
extremely risky I also think I just said
that I think that the basic problem of
the financial crisis is the
undercapitalization of the financial
sector and I think it does not have a
little bit normal words yes so that the
banks are working with too much debt
when things go wrong just a little bit
they go bankrupt and they have to rely
on the state that is basically it's
wrong it's a state supported economy so
many make profits when they make profit
and extra profits they have bonuses and
then a big losses it's for the state yes
and that is the moral problem of the
financial system that it's essentially
an institutional problem they have you
don't see a problem of lack of a good
amount No well of course that is maybe
managing the unemployment we have now in
the UK for example in Europe is it
voluntary or involuntary and now that's
a big problem and it has to do with a
complete crisis of confidence but what
really should happen in a financial
sector is that banks and insurance
companies are adequately capitalized why
are and I think everybody knows that the
policymakers know that that has to
happen and buys demand why is that what
does it mean well why is it not
happening because in the short run it
might lead to less extension of loans so
in the short run it might lead to a
little bit less economic growth I think
those dangers are exaggerated I think if
you really require banks to have
adequate capital what they will they
cannot give these high salaries anymore
they'll have to moderate their
remuneration that way they can
recapitalize much quicker than is
happening right now
but the fear of short-term economic
downturn which is in the current
circumstance is extremely understandable
but prevent us from taking the measures
that are truly necessary in true reform
okay so summarizing you perhaps a little
bit to you know making a bit of a
caricature of you you say it says there
may be a lack of effective aggregate
demand or maybe came to an appointment
but the real that's for my concern I'm a
bit like dr. Pangloss we have to stick
it out but we have to really solve the
provenance your problem of the banks
they have to be recapitalized
if that means that means that they have
to build up their that their balance
sheets if that means that they're not
lending out enough money to the economy
in the economy is a bit slow we just
have to wait it out in ten years you
just need to sit out yeah I know I hear
it very clearly and it's a very strong
view the word of a real banker okay so
my view my view sir I should rent a
house has been a banker in his young
days
I worked for a government owned bank but
anyway yeah so I'm sorry so so my view
is that a lot of what was said is I
don't disagree with also like you were
saying earlier that also the IMF is
learning lessons from this crisis so I
think that crisis in part is learning
technical lessons that bad economics
good economics but what I must say I do
like very much about professors Kelsie's
bukas that I think there's also a moral
element to it all because you know the
technique will not bring us you know to
the to the perfect understanding there
are things we don't understand it has to
do with behavior it has to do with
behavior that is not always you know
something you can steer with economic
incentives it has to do with personal
responsibility and I think it is
interesting then to look at the crisis
in Canada Canada is a country that has
exactly our economic model capitalism
markets modern economics but when
through the crisis very well and that is
because there in policy in the banks
that is just a bit more conservatism
people are just a little bit more
prudent a little bit more careful some
modesty some moderation and these are
words I see in the book and I think that
they are part of the story as the panel
procedures not calling you win yes okay
secretary I guess I agree also that's
the part of the financial crisis is that
our our financial system especially the
banks are very well under capitalized so
that should be restored in one way or
another and I tend to agree with hounds
that if the price for that will be in
the coming period a lower rate of growth
that would be acceptable but it is hard
to manage that and manage expectations
and what you see at the very moment in
time since the
well our institutions and especially of
course the European politicians aren't
Paranal able to define a sort of path
that leads to into a new situation it's
hard to get trusts for them if you see
the opposite in the United States for
instance there they also recognize that
the banks were very well then the
capitalized after Christ and restored it
in a very short period of time and that
it's important that you do that so
that's that's what we mark the second is
that if you don't do that it's it's it's
very hard to handle the the lack of
demands because as long if you have not
a trustful path to a new situation
governments are more or less restricted
in in their doing because everybody is
uncertain about it but I think the main
thing and that adds to to what your own
has said is that we should make this not
a sort of technical debate about ten
percent of capital ratio or banks or or
whatever but we should have some kind of
an idea what kind of banks there will be
in five or seven years time not only
from a safety point of view I mean that
you bring back then the probability of
default because they are better
capitalized at that moment in time but
what is their asset side what kind of
activities do they give credit on how is
their connection with the real economy
and I think it is very important that
that you define that because only
talking about a reduction in Burchette
to three percent of national income or
capitalizing banks on on a higher level
is it too abstract approach to the
system and you and you never can get
public supports for that kind of idea
because you only see the negatives of it
so what would you really should try to
define is what I would call a new social
contracts between the financial sector
on the one hand and society on the other
at that you define what kind of social
problems
you you can expect that the financial
sector will be helpful to solve them
maybe you talk about let's say
alternative sources of energy you can
talk about all kinds of things but as
long as there is not a search of common
goal
for why you do these all the all these
things to bring banks in a better
position in in relation with society I
guess it will how could banks be
reformed innovated they would contribute
in somewhere in order to the good life
first first thing they could do is the
first step in reform is to make them
much more customer friendly I know that
that's probably the most important thing
for most people that they actually get a
service from their banks which which you
know satisfies them of course it's very
important to have a banking system that
doesn't collapse every 10 years and and
and and and and for that you do need a
lot of restructuring I mean I'd have
more competitive banks that separate our
various things all these are well
discuss but I'm not actually that
interested in them I'm afraid not being
a banker I mean if I were a banker I'd
be immensely interest in that regard
this is the core of the problem banks
must be allowed to heal and they must be
encouraged to heal and there are lots of
ways this can be done and they're very
very useful but that is not the way to
get out of the present hole the banks
are not part of the solution for the
present problem they're too damaged to
do that and and as for the idea that um
you know we wait 10 years 10 years
that's 20 to 30 in the life of a young
person and and and what what's more I
would quote Keynes in the long run we're
all dead if you if you say well look you
can't do much now it's all very
difficult because the banks have to be
given time there but to be recapitalized
where are they going to get the capital
from this is very serious problem let's
have a new social contract no bla bla
bla bla bla me
while there are a lot of people whose
lives are being completely wasted not
only people who are actually unemployed
but people who are much less fully
employed than they'd like to be so
that's where my moral I get very angry
when I hear a lot of this stuff because
I'm not I'm not contemptuous of the
technicality behind it I have a great
respect for that but it seems to be
missing the point
but currently with the the British
government is being heavily criticised
along these lines for not doing enough
to support the economy it is already it
perhaps people will find this very
abstract but they already have a debt of
over ninety percent of Gd beats growing
at ten percent per year but war
approximately and why well not because
they are not spending enough I mean to
me it is beyond belief that the British
economy can get out of these problems by
the by the government's creating even a
bigger deficit of over ten percent that
that that that is going to be paid by
those young people that are waiting for
opportunity on a job market but they
will have to pay that that in ten years
time and so it's very easy to say this
is at the expense of the young
generation who are now topless well
first of all the British economy is
still doing relatively well in terms of
of jobs attractive but these drinking
but these people yes but how old the
forecast what a forecast especially if
it's shrinking if the very sinking
because of the tightening of the fiscal
policy of the government but if the if
the British covered economy would grow
more by increasing deficit spending of
the British government it would be one
of the best performing economies in
Europe because it has a very high
deficit already
as
that problem is neat local that problem
is knees Lok in the same hand little
bossy okay either either in the youthful
felt that our local applausing 4sd del
sonido var can be please speaking
British in English so having heard what
the some members of the public are
saying I think they've got a point and
I'm going to good so so what they saying
I will translate is a kind of search and
anger of if the kind of saying saying
that look there is no solution yet we
have to stick it out because I think if
I know you well enough you have a
solution and let me put it so monetary
policy is kind of run its course because
we can lower interest rates anymore we
see Europe the Netherlands and Germany
and particularly suffering from some
budgetary anorexia that the kind of it
like like a dog you know that the more
we stick within free percent the better
and and I think a and you get angry so
what would your your your your the
chancellor of the exchequer not just for
the UK but for all of Europe well let's
not go too far what would you do
see I think I'm not any morally angry
but quite intellectually angry be kind
of soon I think
I think with respect I think you've got
the story the wrong way around the
governments are trying to cut their
deficits they are trying to cut their
deficits and their deficits are growing
why are they not successful in cutting
their deficits they are cutting spending
they are cutting spending and their
economies are shrinking now one of my
position is that is not the way to
reduce your deficit and it's going to
fail let's go back to some of these
general questions and maybe if the panel
members don't mind but let me also
refree have you got a particular
question was I have many questions to
ask on these general issues because and
I have to put it back to you and ask an
inspiring question for mister Lord
Skidelsky well I also got the impression
that
we have assembly somebody from the
anglo-saxon world coming over to the
Rhineland world and telling him about
telling us about how the anglo-saxon
world is is not working well and how we
should they should strive for less work
here in the Rhineland world we are
actually doing that to more extent is it
is it not so that the anglo-saxon world
should simply use our more Rhineland
dick models and and okay Susu use our
quarters this is who he had some debate
on this earlier but but let's go back to
that so we we noted before that in the
US and the UK they work many more hours
than seen the Netherlands and the rest
of Europe is really good part of your
book be rant to say the British readers
be a bit more like the Rhine landing
models the answer is yes yes
his miles to jail question and in fact
in various bits of the book I didn't
have time to go into it this morning we
do draw on the right hand model and also
on Scandinavian social democracy we also
draw on Catholic Catholic social theory
which has been very influential in the
creation of the the European and the
German social market economy we say
there are different models of different
models of how a capitalist system works
and we pay particular we ask a
particular question about how the Dutch
managed to do and that say it's not a
question of your right I mean in a way
we have our own with complaining about
our own conditions in Britain and the
United States and how they're fallen
short of short of what other countries
have been able to do but we still think
having settled that there's a bit of a
lag I think you could do more along
along the lines of economic
possibilities for our grandchildren but
certainly the Netherlands would be very
high up in in you know Keynes which
would be much would be more favorable to
what's happened in the Netherlands than
it would to what's been happening in the
UK you didn't have a fatter or Reagan
and that was your great your great
benefit and the philosopher whose
interest
economics and it seems to me that in
your definition of leisure there is
quite a lot of work because in fact you
call it work freely and joyfully
undertaken you call it purposefulness
without purpose so would I be right to
think that in fact what you're saying is
that the good life considered consists
of having a purpose and doing things and
creating things and making things and
enjoying that life but only some of
those hours should be spent in paid work
and we should liberate the rest of the
time to do that with our lives yeah
having your own purpose yes your own
purpose not a crucial distinction
between the work is that it's not
working on somebody else's creative
project yeah yeah or a creative project
there's a team that I mean we've tried
to distinguish we extrinsic and
intrinsic reasons for activity we're in
problems of semantics and they're quite
difficult because we attach profits
precise meanings to work and leisure and
we're trying to overcome that polarity
but I'm not sure we found exactly the
right language